Aber ich habe gerade vorhin erzählt, ich war bis kurz bevor wir angefangen haben, habe ich im Garten gearbeitet und hat das gerade noch gereicht, eben den Tee aufzuließen, um noch nicht ihn zu trinken.
Nein, ich kann warten.
Nein, ist alles gut. Bin ich soweit.
Zur großen Überraschung bin ich schon wieder eine Frau.
Ja.
Gut.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Uslogu-Lare. Ich bin heute hier der dieshabende Arzt und möchte ich Ihnen das Anamnesi-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache mir hilft jemand. Mir geht so schlecht, ja.
Ja, ich bin hier und ich möchte Ihnen helfen.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maria Stettner.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, Maria, N-A-R-I-A.
Ja.
Und der Familienname ist Tee-E-Tee-N-E-R.
N-E-R.
E-R.
Stettner.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Und wann ist sie genau geboren?
Am 1.3.63 bin ich geboren.
1.3.1963.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin so 1.67. Steht im Pass.
Ja. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, so knapp 70 Kilo.
Gut.
Ja, Frau Stettner. Was für Sie zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so gräßliche Bauchschmerzen.
Und es wird kaum besser.
Und ich musste mich auch schon übergeben.
Und ich habe so richtige, ja, es kommt so in Wellen,
dass ich diese Bauchschmerzen habe.
Und sobald ich mich ein bisschen bewege,
wird es schlechter.
Und wenn ich mich übergeben habe,
dann geht es mir hinterher auch für einen Moment wieder besser.
Aber dann geht es schon wieder los.
Ja, Frau Stettner, seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, gestern Abend ist das losgegangen.
Ja, und sind die Schmerzen plöster begonnen, oder?
Ja, ja.
Plöster.
Und können Sie bitte beschreiben,
wo die Schmerzen genau sind?
Ja, so. Ich würde sagen,
ich habe es im Magen so, am ehesten.
Aber Magen und aber auch im Unterbauch,
ich musste jetzt auch seit ein paar Stunden,
muss ich auch ständig auf die Toilette
und habe ganz starken Durchfall.
Durchfall auch.
Okay.
Streitende Schmerzen in andere Körperteile aus?
Nee, der Bauch, das ist der eine einzige,
ein einziges Ding, so das tut alles weh.
Streit aber nicht aus.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Durchfall.
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Struktur,
hat sich Ihr Konsistenz,
das Struktur weistrig oder wasrig?
Ist das wässrig?
Ja, das läuft so wie Wasser durch.
Ja, wässrig.
Und haben Sie Brut im Struktur bemerkt, oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen rot war das, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Ein bisschen rot.
Und Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben erbrochen.
Ja.
Wie ist Ihre Erbrochen, haben Sie Brut, oder wie Farbe?
Brut habe ich ja nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass das Essen war, was ich am Abend gegessen habe.
Und verdautes Essen, oder?
Ja, ich habe gestern Abend ein Mitbrötchen gegessen.
Und Tomate mit Mozzarella.
Sonst vertraue ich das eigentlich, aber keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Tag, sind Sie gemessen auf einer Skala,
nur bis 10 Uhr?
Ja, ich habe gestern Abend ein Mitbrötchen gegessen.
Und Tomate mit Mozzarella.
Sonst vertraue ich das eigentlich, aber keine Ahnung.
Die Skala nur bis 10 Uhr.
Wenn nur sehr leichter,
sehen Sie starker ist.
Wenn da gerade so eine Welle kommt,
so eine Kolik, dann sind die Schmerzen bestimmt so bei 7,
8.
Und sonst vielleicht bei 5.
Und wie können Sie beschreiben,
dass die Schmerzen sehr kolikartig sind,
Mit allem zusammen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, gestern Abend habe ich mal gemessen, als das losging, da hatte ich 38 und ein bisschen.
38. Haben Sie Schütterprost?
Nein, das nicht. Ich fühle mich nur wirklich schlecht.
Haben Sie gleiche Beschwerde früher gehabt?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen empfindlichen Magen, aber so eine Geschichte,
dass das so schlimm ist, das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Also in vielen Jahren nicht.
Gibt es so hause gleiche Beschwerderpersonen?
Ach so, außer mir hat niemand das mitgegessen.
Ich lebe alleine.
Und wie ist sich Ihr Gewicht in der letzten Zeit verandert?
Nein, leider nicht. Das ist immer stabil.
Haben Sie abgesehen?
Nein, ich habe nicht abgenommen.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Normalerweise nicht, nicht.
Können Sie gut schlafen oder haben Sie nicht gut einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Ich habe ein bisschen Sorgen wegen meiner Tochter, aber normalerweise kann ich schon gut schlafen.
Warum haben Sie über Tochter Sorgen?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich bin alleine erziehend und meine Tochter ist drogenabhängig
und ist aktuell in so einem Methadon-Programm drin.
Da weiß man natürlich nie, was am nächsten Tag passiert.
Haben Sie gegen diese Beschwerde mit dem Kommentar einen genommen?
Nein, ich bin gar nicht zugekommen.
Und dass der wahrscheinlich sofort wieder rausgekommen, wenn ich irgendetwas genommen hätte.
Haben Sie Brust oder andere Köpfer?
Brust, nein, nur der Bauch zu sehen.
Und Frau Stehtner, haben Sie von Erkrankungen oder leiden Sie an chronischer Krankheit,
wie ich wissen sollte, z.B. Bruthochdruh, Brutzuckerkrankheit?
Nein, ich habe ein bisschen Reizmagen und ich habe chronischen Husten,
aber muss ich dazu sagen, ich rauche auch.
Aber wissen Sie, ich bin Taxifahrerin und wenn man da so lange warten muss,
dann raucht man eben schon mal eine Zigarette.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und dann nehmen Sie regelmäßig mit Kommentar oder je regiert nicht ein?
Eigentlich nehme ich nur, weil bedarf, wenn ich nachts nicht schlafen kann,
oder wenn ich so unruhig bin, nehme ich Baldrian
und wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe, nehme ich Aspirin.
Ja, und wurden Sie schon operiert?
Ja, nicht wirklich operiert, bei der Geburt,
das war eine Saublockengeburt, als meine Tochter auf die Welt gekommen ist.
Das ist jetzt 27 Jahre her.
Ja, Kaiser scheint schädlich.
Nein, nein, nein, eine Vakuumentbindung, also Saublocken.
Und ja, und haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich kann tatsächlich Penicillin vertragen.
Penicillin?
Wie oisert die Penicillin-Zeitsch, Penicillin-Allergie?
Ja, ich kriege also einen Ausschlag, ne?
Okay, haben Sie Unverträglichkeit gegen Medikamente, oder?
Nein, sonst habe ich nichts.
Okay, und Sie haben erwähnt, Sie ist raucherin,
wie viele Zigarette technisch rauchen Sie?
Ja, also ein knappes Päckchen am Tag rauch ich wohl schon.
Ein Päckung.
Ja, also ich habe das jetzt in den letzten 10 Jahren ein bisschen reduziert,
jetzt vielleicht noch eine halbe Packung, aber früher habe ich schon ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Wieder mehr Zigarette rauchen Sie?
Nee, jetzt eher weniger.
Es ist halbe, halbe, ja.
Und wie lange haben Sie gerauchen Sie?
Ach, so, seit dem 20. Lebensjahr rauch ich bestimmt.
Ja, das war nicht der Lebensjahr.
Wir haben ungefähr 40 Jahre gerauchert.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich, würde ich mal sagen, 2 Glitter Wein pro Woche,
oder auch manchmal Bier im Sommer.
Gedecklich.
Okay, das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie schon Drogen probiert?
Ja, das langt mir die Erfahrung mit meiner Tochter.
Tochter.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie leben alleine, waren Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden, ja.
Und Sie haben eine Tochter.
Und Sie sind Taxifahrer.
Ja.
Und sind Ihre Eltern am Leben,
oder haben Sie chronische Krankheiten, wie ich wissen sollte?
Also meine Eltern leben beide nicht mehr.
Und die sind auch beide nicht alt geworden.
Mein Vater hatte mit 55 in Herzenfahrt.
Und meine Mutter ist mit 65 an einem Brustkrebs gestorben.
Oh, tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Waren Sie schon im Ausland?
Überhaupt schon mal, ja, aber jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht.
Und wurden Sie gegen Corona vollständig geimpft?
Ja, klar, wenn ich Taxifahrer habe, habe ich ja viel Kontakt mit Leuten.
Da muss ich schon geimpft sein, ne?
Ja, da bin ich dreimal geimpft.
Sie haben chronische Hüsten.
Gibt es inzwischen ihre Hüsten, Steigern,
oder haben sie Hüstenattacken?
Ja, das ist nur so, dass das immer mal wieder kommt.
Und sobald ich ein bisschen schlechtes Wetter ist,
oder ich ein bisschen kalt geworden bin,
oder so, kriege ich sofort wieder Hüsten.
Dann werde ich fast nicht los.
Haben Sie Grider Schmerzen oder Gelenk Schmerzen?
Im Augenblick nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Stechner, ich habe wichtige Fragen gesteckt.
Möchtest du etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ich möchte jetzt nur, dass mir etwas besser geht,
weil ich diese Bauchschmerzen loswerden will
und diese Übelkeit loswerden will.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich muss sofort ihnen körperlich unterlesen
und einen Zugang legen und Flüssigkeit durchführen.
Und sollte ich natürlich Medikamente geben
und über Erbrechen und Schmerzen geben.
Das ist gut, ja.
Ich glaube, Sie haben eine Magen- und Darmen-Entzündung.
Aber ich habe gesagt,
erst möchte ich einige diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen
und danach könnte ich Ihnen dazu mehr sagen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Okay.
Also von mir aus sind wir fertig, ja?
Mit dieser Runde hat jemand noch ergänzende Fragen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie fühlen sich fibrig.
Haben Sie die Temperatur gemessen?
Ja, die haben gemessen.
Ja, 18.30.
Gestern Abend habe ich gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Buschrott.
Aber wie viel oder wie oft müssen Sie Stuhlkrank geben?
Alle Stunde.
Jede Stunde.
Sehr oft.
Und im Ausland war ich nicht nein.
Ja, ich habe dafür.
Was ich nicht weiß, ob Sie das richtig verstanden haben,
was ich Dressliches gegessen habe.
Ich habe ein Mettbrötchen gegessen.
Sie haben gesagt, Mettbrötchen.
Mettbrötchen.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Das ist rohes Fleisch mit Zwiebeln.
Jetzt muss ich dazu sagen,
dass dieser Fall, der fehlt mir echt schwer,
weil ich nämlich Vegetarier bin.
Allein der Gedanke an ein Mettbrötchen,
da kriege ich auch Bauchwehe.
Ich habe bemerkt, ich war Mutter, aber ich bin nicht sicher, was das ist.
Das ist tatsächlich rohes Fleisch mit Zwiebeln.
Oh, raunvoll.
Das geschmeckt mir.
Es gibt Leute, die essen das mit großer Begeisterung.
Allein der Gedanke, da kriege ich Schweißausbrüche.
Deswegen habe ich den Fall bisher auch noch nie gemacht.
Ja, gut.
Dann ist es klar.
Sind Sie soweit?
Ja, ich kann anfangen.
Wir können weitermachen.
Frau Oberarsten Haben, Sie seid sehr gut.
Frau Oberarsten Haben, Sie seid, ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, gerne.
Frau Maria Stechner ist eine 59-Jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,67 m groß und 70 kg schwer.
Die Patientin, die sich bei uns wegen jetzt
vor gestern Abend plötzlich aufgetreten hat,
hat sich getrennt, die Kohleartiger mit Bauchsmärzeln
und Diare und Gomitus vor.
Die Patienten berichtete, dass diese Beschwerden nach dem Abendessen aufgetreten seien.
Diese Beschwerden hätten sich im Verlauf derzeit verschlechtert.
Die Patienten mussten sehr oft auf die Toilette gehen.
Die Konsistenz des Schutuls sei wässrig.
Die Patienten haben ein bisschen Blut im Schutul gesehen.
Die Patienten sind auf die Begleitung gefallen.
Die Patienten haben keine Medikamente oder keine Medikamente.
Die Patienten reagieren allergisch mit Exanten.
Die Patienten sind auf die Begleitung gefallen.
Die Patienten haben Fleisch mit Zwiebeln gebraten.
Was wissen wir denn, war das gut gekühlt?
Das gilt ja Rohesfleisch, gerade Hackfleisch mit der vergrößerten Oberfläche.
Das gilt ja als hochpräsent.
Rohesfleisch muss man super schnell verbrauchen.
Das ist kein Rohesfleisch mehr drin.
Was könnte das sein?
Das ist ein Rohesfleisch.
Das ist eine Veränderung der Haut.
Das ist für die Appendicitis.
Das machen sie relativ zügig.
Das ist eine Veränderung der Haut.
Ich bin als Patientin zufrieden.
Ich habe ein komisches Mettbrötchen losgeworden.
Hat jemand von den Kollegen noch Ergänzungen oder Kommentare?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich weiß, dass es die Empfehlung gibt, dass man, wenn man nicht alleine lebt,
im Haus eine eigene Toilette haben sollte.
Man muss sich nicht sicherstellen, dass es ein Familienhaushalt ist.
Ich bin nicht sicher, dass es ein Familienhaushalt ist.
Ihre Prüfung ist am Dienstag.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Die anderen sehe ich am Dienstag.
Ich habe gesehen, dass Dr. Gündes wieder da ist.
Sind Sie auf Dr. Mehmet Bees Account?
Ich habe gesehen, dass ich Sie sehe.
Wenn Sie nur Bescheid sagen, dass wir uns am Dienstag wieder sehen.
Dienstag 20 Uhr.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Wenn jemand noch zwischen Durchprüfung hat und nicht dabei ist,
wünsche ich schon mal Teutäutäu.
Ich sehe Sie am Dienstag.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.